hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
it's still the season of Christmas I'm
still in the mood to torture myself so
let's take a look at our next holiday
stinker the he-man and Shera Christmas
special
[Music]
just saying the title of this makes me
laugh my ass off I mean what's next
Thundercats Christmas a GI Joe Christmas
hell I would be surprised if there was a
Star Wars Christmas you will be you will
be and it's just as silly as you may
think of it I hate to admit I didn't
watch a ton of he-man or she were
growing up so I might miss a few
characters maids and such but I do
remember the basic press a prince named
Adam lives in the world of Eternia where
somehow taking off his clothes disguises
his identity and turns him into he-man
he has a magic sword who fights off a
bonehead named Skeletor
she was same story though with its so
die beggar wondering how they bring
Christmas into that Plateau well let's
take a look this is the he-man and Shera
christmas special
so it turns out is he managed she was
birthday as the king and queen of
Eternia set up the castle for a
celebration talk at it it looks like a
gay pride parade in the Land of Oz yeah
yeah I know I've been like a bajillion
gay jokes about you man in the past well
all right as a special Christmas gift I
will not make any more gay jokes about
he-man I hope you appreciate my
sacrifice cuz it ain't easy so we see
all the rejected Disney characters set
up the castle and get ready for the
party
I think purple would look good up there
pika blue
you know it reminds me of how we used to
get ready for Christmas at this time of
year Christmas what's that an earth
holiday a very special earth holiday
yeah that's all we're gonna say about
apparently Maxine they're almost
finished kata so it turns out
man-at-arms and he-man oh I'm sorry
Adam yeah is uh this guy's really throw
me off there are launching a rocket that
can hopefully spy on Skeletor but you
tell me how the hell a loud fire spewing
warhead is gonna spy on anything this
little sky spy will give us a complete
picture of skeletor's every move but our
little chihuahua poltergeist named Orko
wants to take a closer look
[Music]
[Applause]
what happened well remember that easily
breakable piece of the handle that we
designed to launch the whole ship maybe
we should have dumped it so is our space
kaduche flies into the sky we get our
opening cringe unless the rest of the
title is go backdoor humping I'm not
interested yeah I think you never
thought you hear jingle bells and he-man
together unless you replace the letter e
and belt with the letter A okay okay I
made a promise
what's happening skeletal is going after
the sky spy then he man's going after
Skeletor
by the power of Grayskull
[Music]
hey sis I have the power I got a feeling
my brother may need some help
oh the transformations aren't even a big
deal anymore she could be doing the
dishes
you're trying to grab more than you can
handle
okay I'm not gonna make any more gay
jokes but for the record I want to
countdown of how many gay jokes I could
have made you're trying to grab more
than you can handle
but the evil Skeletor tries to trap a
man
[Music]
Oh dad that's the last time we try to
save money by buying stock to take
breaths
[Music]
but luckily he's saved by Wonder Woman
riding rainbow Brites unicorn let's get
a little fresh air
the sky spy it's spinning up into space
hey how come our air isn't blowing even
though with thousands of feet in the air
so they followed the rocket to see if
they can get it back good thing they can
breathe in space I'm afraid we've lost
your sky spy no it's a good thing
nobody's in it
well nobody redeemable so we see or go
making his way towards Earth as Earth so
he runs into two children who I guess
we're looking for a Christmas tree in
the mountains
[Music]
yeah maybe have a cellphone on there we
can contact somebody they can come up
here and rescue us that'd be wonderful
oh by the way to walk you said you were
looking for a Christmas tree Oh what's
Christmas when you get lots of present
but it's also a time when everybody
thinks about peace and goodwill toward
men angel will tell you the whole story
[Music]
those are Earth's coordinates Orko's
landed on earth are you saying that
we'll never get or go back oh sorry I'm
trained to do that every time those
words are others have no Teela my
transport beam might do it the problem
is it needs a carrying water crystal to
power it and there are none here on
Eternia yeah ok let me just tell you
what they're really saying you see my
insert technobabble here might solve it
but we need a random technical plot
point thingy in order to make it work
I'll find one good bring me a present
when you get back then they're done that
next scene
man follow the star until they finally
reached Bethlehem oh good we didn't miss
anything important and it looks like
we're gonna miss that part too you know
I just love Christmas specials then
totally ignore Christmas
[Music]
Oh God
every time this happens I feel
unbelievable pain God I think sprouting
these wings the chick is as I heart
[Music]
so we flight to the plan of New Jersey
when they try to find the water crystal
if they need to locate Orko the Beast
monster isn't that a little redundant
and he isn't that kind like saying look
out The Tortoise turtle he's evil bad
but fortunately this monster is
unbelievably stupid which results in
Shira getting the water crystal with no
problem
that is until another monster pops up it
looks as though we found something else
too what all day wait a minute wait a
minute that's the unicorns voice it's
like the most fun whimsical thing I've
ever heard they're changing into on the
phone okay I'm pushy right but aren't
you the coins supposed to be like Swift
and elegant
I mean what girl wants to hear that you
look quite safe come on Cheryl let's
fight some evil doors maybe we can drop
by the cigar store on the way there that
just doesn't sound right so luckily this
monster doesn't seem too bad to defy it
[Music]
oh my god those transforming robots are
transforming into some kind of
transformed evil I think they're called
care pairs so she or I has to use all of
her brains and all of her fighting
skills to come up with a way to get
themselves out that was easy
she then gets the crystal to man-at-arms
a man just to bring or go home all we
have to do is hold hands and we'll over
there in Eternia we call this a
kidnapping fairies who are your friends
who are your friends I'm looking I'm
Casey Kasem enjoy psiphon no meanwhile
we could to a burnt potato chip or a
horde prime who I guess at the evil
overlords fears the presence of goodwill
known as Christmas is harshing his
people so he summons Skeletor and has
some other villain whose name I can't
really understand
poor wreck go Track Pack I don't care
[Music]
what the hell am I even looking at if
the ruler of darkness just a flaming
turd that nobody can make out what the
hell is he even saying look it's given
to his face he clearly has no idea what
he's talking about
no not getting any of this is that
English
you need to enunciate I have no lips and
even I can enunciate
have no fear great master I will yeah
what he said
but it turns out there's some
disagreements between these evildoers
you you can't even handle that
muscle-bound female sirrah just a minute
what about the way he manhandled you so
you heard right horde prime the evil
ruler of Darkness wants to in fact steal
Christmas beat oh gosh why no one quite
knows the reason but that's okay the
kids are helping the people of Eternia
right all new Christmas songs there sure
become household classics
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the Christmas spirit I beg to
differ
but unfortunately the evil troops come
down to Wow
I mean Lowery how could a show that's
not trying to insert gay symbolism
constantly be doing this by was frozen
today so for hack attack whatever
kidnaps the kids at Orko but is
intercepted by the gobots here just
answer the list so they were imprisoned
by the evil machines but luckily some
characters called man Sheen's yes that's
really what they're called come in to
help where the man chains my name is
cutter yes what I do
I also make pies so he man Shira and the
scrap metal from Megaman all tried to
help him save the kids get you all up
[Music]
what works for my sister works for me
yeah it's been a while let's put a toy
swag in this is a Christmas special
after all
[Music]
but Skeletor comes in and kidnaps the
kids again we'll see about that
Oh chief only he can fly why do I sect
how how can I hear anybody so the crash
into the mountains where Skeletor
actually has to spend some quality time
with the kids
get moving Yuto we have a long time
Christmas time Christmas time I'm Jewish
I get eight candles a dreidel and a new
pair of slacks every year I'll be as
fucking grouchy as I please you little
Hitler youths now move it season of love
and joy and caring
Wow I guess that line took everything
however now get moving you two before
her dad comes back we're so cool lastik
now that made you ponder doesn't it
why would Skeletor add a coat creating
device on his evil magic wand my wand
can do anything it can kill people
destroy cities how many fashionable fat
coats but why why why why forgets toad
people need to keep their body heat as a
neutral level it also makes the little
umbrellas that you put at the top of
drapes who would use it to burn have you
ever had a pina colada or without one of
those little umbrellas on top it's
depressing nobody should be subjected to
that kind of evil oh I am stand tall but
it appears the Christmas spirit is so
strong it even seems to affect the bony
Lord of evil himself no I said leave him
Oh blast it don't know what's coming
over me but if you dare chew on one of
my bones I swear you're the first one
I'm eating Sue's a bitch are long they
come across a man Shira blow rock back
whatever and even horde prime as they
all meet up to have a huge bet now hand
them over
you just shot my goody Goods because
this is what you think of when you think
of Christmas right people beating that
shit out of each other
[Music]
so just as horde Prime is about to kill
the kids
Skeletor feels the Christmas spirit once
more and fights him off and I must save
the children get away from her you bitch
so what Prime is destroyed and they be
the kids back home
these aren't our parents why Adam even
dresses up like Santa Claus oh you know
it was me all the time didn't you well
it's not nearly as good as your he meant
us guys next I tried taking off more
clothes and of course we get one of
those lame-ass messages at the end of
every episode first it's a season of
love and joy and caring presents are
nice Arco but Christmas means much more
than that I know it's about making other
religions feel inferior
that's right Orca and what would make
you have is this Christmas how about a
pair of fucking lights so that's the key
manage your a Christmas special it's
pretty silly it makes no sense but to be
fair with you to expect from he-man and
Shera it's stupid but it's harmless and
that's about all you can say about it I
mean there's a lot of things out there
that could be worse for example I'd be
terrified if there really was a Star
Wars Christmas special you will be you
will be why does he keep saying that
[Music]